hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the joy of creation
reborn now this is the game that I was
telling you about in the last one made
by the same person but this one involves
free roaming which means that I'll be
exploring the house that they're all in
and if lovely Freddy out there is any
indication there's going to be a joyous
time yes you talked about you buddy
let's have fun together
let's discover the joy of creation now
if you remember the joy of creation is
actually an excerpt from something that
was in the first five nights at Freddy's
game I thought I heard fitness and in
the first five nights at Freddy's game
oh oh I haven't played this before I
haven't even seen gameplay hello who are
you
am i or am i ain't happenin am i an
animatronic oh man hello
ah my jam okay well if sure is setting
the mood for something horrible to
happen whoa what the far I broke it oh
god I broke it
whoops okay I fell through the floor
there it's just an alpha by the by in
case you guys didn't know okay we're
back I'm not gonna do that again I'm
gonna try to break the game so
apparently I'm an animatronic and this
is what I'm talking about this how's it
going oh okay it's really dark also
where's my arm I may not actually be an
animatronic but if I am I'm I'm a little
curious as to why I'm roaming around the
house Oh am i stalking someone
Zach oh what happened oh my god
I just hear this thumping behind I
didn't even know if that was like in the
game or in real life I was like taking a
legitimate moment to be like haha
someone banging on my door holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that okay so
apparently I'm not stalking anybody I'm
still being stalked [ __ ]
okay so apparently there's a trap down
there it's a phone oh come on man
so I'm gonna avoid any walls altogether
because apparently the floor is very
fragile oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude
uh-huh
hey buddy I'm glad my microphone is in
the really in the game holy [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] man I don't
even know what my objective is other
than just to survive I really don't know
what I'm trying to go for here I really
don't know
is there anything then I need to get
because I can't see it oh I have a
flashlight I didn't know is he going
away I better be going away from me hi
buddy hey that's good I really don't
want to run into him again they don't
know why I'm here oh my god coming this
way uh-huh okay
I'll take that oh my god oh my god oh
that wasn't a stumpy robot arm that was
my flashlight literally the whole time
oh man that's terrifying okay I I
haven't been looking very closely for
things so I'm going to try to look
so there's gotta be whatever they may
not be there may not be anything for me
to get in here what was that okay I
thought that was bloodstains on the wall
whose curtains
what about doing oh my god oh my god oh
that's so creepy can you see my
flashlight I don't know oh so weird hey
buddy hey hey buddy
which way you going buddy what's where
you going so it doesn't seem like
there's any other door around here it
just kind of seems like it's an enclosed
space and there's just me and him him
and me alone together
mano a mano in a house can he spot me
from all the way down the hallway
probably the answer is probably yes
where did he go I don't know where he
went
you like vanished is he over there I
think I see a flashlight moving or like
his eyeballs moving oh thank you oh good
imagine huh
huh-uh so once he gets you he's got you
good
he's got you forever there's no escaping
him holy [ __ ] that is so cool that has
so much potential I'm gonna go in one
more time not that there's anything else
for me to discover unless there is I'm
gonna look very hard but I don't know if
there is but I'm gonna try this one more
time we shall see what I find that was
yeah oh it's all of them III didn't see
Bonnie's ears before oh why are Bonnie's
eyes red holy [ __ ] it's no good at all
all right here we go I can't read them
why can't I read anything here I'm like
blind I went in without my glasses all
right let's do this bud
okay so first I'm gonna scan everything
in the environment but it just seems to
be repeating basic stuff
gonna have us get out war sides if like
a boss okay there's gotta be I mean
there doesn't got to be anything there
definitely doesn't got to be anything it
could just be emptiness Chris Farsi I
can see oh whoa you creepy and I think
that's what it is like of course this is
an alpha so there's no real game yet
do-do-do-do-do wait is he coming this
way
who's that what's that that was
something that was new what was that oh
it's just him is this him activating his
servos and going every which away I
think in the goddamn trash can
ooh why is that the only working light
in this whole place just to identify the
center of the map this would be
ludicrously scary on VR I mean like VR
with just playing with a gamepad cuz you
couldn't obviously walk around the
building but oh I'm gonna try to sneak
up behind him yeah yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
whoa
okay he's going that way
did you hear me
no those are such a dough's playing with
oh my god oh my god oh god oh I don't
know what I expected he doesn't like the
flashlight whoa okay all right so that
is the joy of creation that is awesome
the animations of him are actually
pretty phenomenal like that game in its
entirety the potential for this to have
something more is really good there's a
lot of potential here I want to see more
of this even though it has few bugs but
obviously this is just a demo this is an
alpha Simon a game yet it's just a tech
demo and but what it is is amazing and
terrifying even if it wasn't five nights
at freddys this is a good concept but
the fact that it's an animatronic scares
me personally just cuz I hate mannequins
in animatronic so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to see me
play those nights at Rachel's which is
made by the same guy obviously this
person knows quality - a few bugs but
knows quality in general so let me know
in the comments and thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video oh boy
I'm so happy that I'm here in this world
of air or